all right so there's about two types of
people in this world apparently people
who see this picture and think oh wow a
red tesla
or people who see this picture and think
whoa what a uneven paint job panel
gapped swirly quality control nightmare
so if you're the first type of person
i've made other videos about tesla and
their competitors they're linked below
just check them out but if you are that
second person well maybe porsche tycan
is for you so this is the porsche tycan
turbo
it starts at well over a hundred
thousand dollars but this is it this is
porsche's all-electric car their
four-door sport sedan so let's see 670
horsepower
250 miles of range
zero to 60 in three seconds
93 kilowatt hour battery
but there's a lot more to a car
than just the numbers
like a lot more
continuity
so i have to see
what this car was all about for myself
like anytime you hear about porsche
tycan this is the car that always comes
up about
porsche and the best electric cars and
the most hyped electric cars
and the best
tesla competitors
and i gotta say after living with this
car for the past
two weeks or so
i think i'm actually a believer
but i have to show you what i mean
so i've talked plenty about electric
cars before this one follows the
familiar battery in the floor between
the wheels for the low center of gravity
thing that the rest of them do but
there's a whole bunch of stuff including
the porsche design stuff that make this
car
a little bit different obviously
porsche's look i happen to think the
front end of this car with the
headlights looks really sweet of course
the whole shape isn't as sporty as some
other models obviously it's a four-door
so it's a little bigger and these arrow
wheels i think look kind of lame hiding
the massive brakes um but overall the
porsche is a good looking sedan even
better looking in white which the the
mission e has always been shown in i
think that's the spec i would want to go
for but besides just the porsche design
stuff there is some stuff that this car
does the way it works that is
fundamentally different from the way
tesla does
an electric car
and i'm using tesla to compare because
that's what i know the best that's what
most people are familiar with
but
yeah it's it's it's closer to the
traditional car world which i think
makes sense coming from porsche but for
one
this interior and look i was one of
those people who didn't really care so
much or think too hard about the
interior of the car and people would
always say tesla's interiors are bad and
i'm like it's fine you're exaggerating
but then i sat in this car
and i will say there's a difference
between interior quality
and interior layout i still prefer the
layout the interior layout of a tesla or
even you know ford uh mustang machi or
some others
but there is no doubt that the quality
of materials with this layout they've
chosen the quality of the interior
is amazing but instead of instead of
just saying that because everyone always
said that to me the porsche interior is
amazing instead of just saying it let me
let me actually show you
so the ti-can interior has screens and
buttons everywhere surrounding you this
spec i'm showing you is actually the
vegan interior but there's a bunch of
different trims you can go for most of
which include all of the following so
the 16.8 inch curved screen dashboard
back there the reachable touchscreen
controls on the sides of that dashboard
for things like the headlights air
suspension height traction control etc
the metal not plastic piece on the door
sill that says tycan turbo these really
really nice firm bolstered seats
alcantara vegan leather precise
stitching everywhere as you'd expect but
also fully adjustable in every dimension
including the headrest which can go
forward and backward and the actual
length of the seat itself which for
taller people is pretty sweet physical
buttons for the three different driver
profiles and then a second touchscreen
in the middle with a lot of the controls
that's pretty responsive but also
impressively has really solid haptic
feedback so it kind of replicates the
feeling of pressing another real button
which is nice a huge physical power
button to turn the car on and off the
physical metal drive mode knob of course
the panoramic glass roof that also
conveniently adds about four inches of
extra headroom to the front seats this
super extra 360 degree camera view which
has a bunch of these views that are like
third-person views of the car which is
also always the white one for some
reason uh lots of controllable ambient
lights throughout the cabin including
the cup holders
huge air vents that are controllable
from the touchscreen like model 3 and
model y so you can choose between
diffused blowing air into the cabin
focused which blows air focused to
actually driving positions of my hands
on the steering wheel or individual
which lets you choose exactly where you
want to blow the air this little motor
inside of the seat belt that actually
pulls it snug across your chest for the
people in the front seats as you start
to drive and get over a certain speed
the lighted powered usb c ports in the
front and even two more between the rear
back seats one for each passenger
and that touch screen in the back lets
them each control their own heated seats
and air conditioner airflow to the same
precision as the front
this little button on the bottom inside
of the steering wheel that turns on the
heated steering wheel and this super low
key wireless charger inside the center
console you slot your phone in there
connect it to the car via bluetooth and
it just starts wireless charging in
there and you can hide it away and it
won't slide around when you start to
drive fast and yes there is apple
carplay
so hopefully that illustrates for you
the point that people have been trying
to make to me for so long it's not just
saying that quality or tolerances are
better
but once you like sit yourself in the
middle of all of this there's even this
little button in the bottom of the
steering wheel all this stuff
it's pretty next level it's great
and now i i kind of hope someday tesla
gets to this level for their interiors
all right let's talk batteries and
charging for a second it's an electric
car so
the tie can over here behind me has on a
good day with a 100 battery a spec of
250 miles but two notes on that number
one the tie can is significantly less
efficient than the tesla
so what that means is you guys all know
miles per gallon for cars for gasoline
for electric cars we measure efficiency
in watt hours per mile or
how much energy it uses to go mile the
lower the better so one of the tesla's
specialties is efficiency all the
millions of miles of driving and
research they have put into powertrain
for electric cars has my average watt
hours per mile number in phantom anyway
usually around 350. on a good day a
little under 300 with some spirited
driving it can be up over 400 right and
that's why they have a long range
version of the model s that can go over
400 miles but the thai can on the other
hand it's very sporty obviously but i
cannot for the life of me get it under
consistently 400 watt hours per mile
typically the way i drive in normal mode
400 to 500 and uh with some more
spirited driving it's easily over 550
600 and you'll see even higher numbers
and so the 250 miles that it's rated for
in the sportier modes can feel a lot
more like 210 220 so number two that's
when you got to talk about charging them
so you can slow charge either of these
at home they both have their own little
charging kits although the porsche's
home charger is a bit bigger and i guess
has a pretty big box that sits on the
ground in your garage but that's fine
but for longer road trips and this
varies depending on what part of the
world you live in but at least here in
the us tesla's supercharging network is
still a pretty big advantage now the
tican uses what's called the electrify
america network of chargers and it's
almost as big
and you can charge just as fast on any
of those fast chargers and that'll get
you anywhere from zero to a hundred
percent battery or somewhere near it in
like 25 minutes which is awesome but
there's just not nearly as many of those
high-powered chargers in the electrify
american networks i mean you can just go
on their sites and look at the two maps
and compare for yourself the fast
chargers available to porsche versus
available to tesla is a pretty big
difference still and those extra
chargers plus the longer range go a long
way towards making a more convenient
driving experience for a road trip in an
electric car so that's something these
cars both do differently at the moment
but i also still kind of wonder why more
new electric cars coming out don't use
tesla's existing supercharged network
right it's out there they've said they
would allow others to use it
but they don't and there was even a
story recently about
some kind of hacking cars that aren't
teslas to use the superchargers so we
know it's possible
it just isn't officially supported yet i
think i'd be way more likely to drive a
tie can confidently every day if i could
just pull up to a supercharger any time
anyway
on to driving
so i meant what i said on twitter
what'd i say on twitter i said that the
porsche tycan is the best driving
electric car out right now period
and i guess i shouldn't really be
surprised because
sports car
driving dynamics
is what porsche does like that's what
they're good at but i'm still impressed
like this car i'm driving right now
weighs
significantly over 5 000 pounds the
sedan i'm driving right now
weighs more than a ford f-150
and that's just the nature of electric
cars right now they're heavy but yet
still the the steering feedback the the
responsiveness it feels more
direct and flat and planted
than anything else in its class anything
else i've driven yes more than a tesla
yes more than a model 3 and a model s
but like
it it doesn't feel light don't get me
wrong you still can understand that this
is a heavy car
but it feels so much sportier than
anything else like it also i shouldn't
leave out this drive mode knob at the
bottom here it's pretty sweet i always
like that tesla lets you change
acceleration suspension on the screen
you can go ludicrous mode and all that
stuff
and
there's a knob for it here and it's a
nice knob there's something about it
being a nice knob like if it was a dumb
plastic knob i'd be like why is there a
knob for it i don't need one but
something about it being a nice metal
knob to change driving modes
pretty cool so tycan has four modes
range mode
normal mode sport
and sport plus so range mode is pretty
self-explanatory it limits you to 70
miles an hour lowers the car to be a
little more aero and you're just trying
to get as much range as possible so that
normal mode is normal driving sport mode
when you flip to that it's going to
stiffen the suspension a little bit and
make the throttle response a little more
direct and then when you go to sport
plus mode it makes it even more
aggressive throttle response even
stiffer and it also lowers the car to be
its more most aggressive
stance
and you can feel it and it also turns on
the uh
electric sports sound
all right so i've pulled over now i'm
going to go to sport plus mode so you
can hear
that sound you can turn it on for other
modes but this is the sound they give
you
[Music]
kind of like a
spaceship type of thing
i guess and i also i swear i can hear it
shifting gears
when it's in this like exaggerated sound
mode i don't know if that sound is added
at a certain speed to make you think oh
it's kind of like a normal car i'm
changing gears but the ti can does have
two-speed gearbox which most other
electric cars don't have and that lets
you keep accelerating harder at higher
speeds
but i don't know if that's like really
when it's shifting but here i'll do it
again so you can hear it so okay we're
at zero
10 20 30
40.
did you hear that did you catch that
like that little
i don't know i don't know if that's
actually when it's changing gears i just
thought that was fascinating and there's
a whole bunch more fascinating stuff in
this car that i haven't even gotten to
dive into the quad led headlights the
door handles that motorize open and
closed the tiny front trunk that can
maybe fit two backpacks the fact that
there's a backup camera and this little
nub here next to it is the backup camera
cleaner
i don't think i've ever seen that before
in a car
the fact that pressing the brakes in
this car doesn't actually squeeze the
brakes right away it actually starts off
using regen with the motors up until a
certain threshold then it adds physical
brakes mixing them together like the
fact that not quite all of this battery
is available to the user and they can
never fully charge the 93 kilowatt hours
cell to a hundred percent ever that of
course is to avoid the battery
degradation that comes from charging to
100 repeatedly the rear wheel steering
the torque vectoring the 800 volt system
that makes the fast charging and heating
and cooling efficiency possible the
consistently hard launches from zero to
sixty until the battery is nearly dead
the two-speed gearbox that i think the
tesla roadster is gonna have to learn
from the fact that there's a charging
door on both sides of the car but you
know i think you're getting the picture
here so all right look at the end of the
day the tie can
is an awesome car no doubt about it it's
an expensive car yes but also it's
porsche what do you expect they don't
really make cheap cars
but
the series of advantages it has at the
end of the day is really impressive the
800 volt system they've built is great
the driving experience is amazing
and i just really like that they
actually put some effort into thinking
about the electric car driving
experience and they didn't they didn't
just cough out an electric version of
another one of the cars they make and
that i think is what makes the thai can
so special and impressive to me not just
the fact that they made an electric car
but the fact that there's different ways
to attack making a great electric
driving experience
kind of like folding phones there's more
than one right answer in all these first
generations so that's the end of my
experience i gotta give the tai can back
now shout out to maurice from porsche of
englewood for coordinating this whole
experience making it possible i'll have
his link below but i want to leave you
guys with this question to end it
because we were thinking about this at
the studio and i think it's a
fascinating question for me
if we were to drop a porsche thai can
or
an equivalent fully loaded tesla
in your driveway right now
which would you take
and would supercharging on the thai can
change that for you
for me i would take the thai can with
supercharging but without it i would
still take the tesla but i'm curious
what you think
either way that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace